okay so what i want to do today is basically
a recap and a very clear explanation of the
situation that we are in economically um at the
moment largely with regards to Covid we're going
to touch obviously on the Russia-Ukraine
situation a little bit but um largely it will
be a recap of the economic situation right now
because we're about 2 years in to Covid now
and we're starting to see the transition which
i've been expecting for a while where this
ceases to be primarily a health crisis and we move
into basically a really acute economic crisis um
people who've been following this
channel especially from the beginning
will be aware that i've been saying
from the very beginning of Covid
that the way we are dealing with it is
going to create massive economic problems
a little bit down the line. now we're seeing
those economic problems coming through
but they are being phenomenally terribly
understood and explained by the mainstream
media so what this means is massive economic
hits are coming in right now to ordinary families
basically what has been called the cost of living
crisis and it's actually very easy to understand
how this is happening and it's been predicted
in early videos on this channel but it's not
being explained it's not being understood and the
way that the government has handled the economic
crisis has actually made it very difficult for
ordinary people to understand what's going on so
what i want to do is basically peel the lid back
on this and explain really clearly what's going on
so it's about a year and a half
now since we started this channel
and at the very beginning of code we put our first
video out well it was about was it July when the
first video went out? something like that, um and
what that video was about was explaining how
the way that Covid has been handled by central
banks (i.e. Bank of England) and governments
led to and would lead to an enormous
increase of cash in the bank accounts of rich
people specifically it's so important that people
understand that so if anybody hasn't watched that
first video on the channel i would recommend
to go and watch it and understand that because
if you want to understand what's happening with
the economy now and what's going to happen in
the next couple of years the number one thing
you need to understand is that big thing that
has changed economically now versus pre Covid
is rich and very rich people in this country and in
other similar countries in Europe, USA, Australia
allover the world - rich people have way way way
way more cash than they had before Covid
No.1 biggest change and the scale of that cannot
be underestimated you know i've i keep talking
about it but it's ten thousand pounds per adult
was the amount of money printed in this country
but it's all gone to the richest sort of ten
twenty percent so each one of those people has
we're talking about each adult so if you have
a family with two adults both of them each one of
them has 70-80000 pounds extra cash in their bank
than pre-covid and the reason why i think this
is really important to emphasize is because you
know most people are not rich or super rich right
so say you're an ordinary person right most of the
people watching this video are ordinary people
they have not accumulated 70 grand during Covid
they don't know that the rich people accumulated
£70,000 during Covid right they don't know
there's no way of them knowing so it's very
important that they are aware of this because
everything that happens now and will happen
in the next sort of 10-15 years economically
will be determined by the fact dominated by the
fact that these rich people have accumulated a
huge amount of money during coving so the
number one thing which everybody needs to
know and i know i'll keep going on about this
but the reason i'm doing this is because the
media are not talking about it and it's a it's
a clean fact right is that the rich people in
this country are sitting on 70-80 grand each cash
more and i want people to just stop and think
of how much money there is 70 80 grand sitting in
their account that wasn't there before coving okay
that's there now and um if you want to understand
how it's explained very clearly first video on
this channel I think it's called "how covid-19
is making the rich richer" that's right right?
um understand that please understand that rich
people are sitting on enormous piles of cash that
was not there before Covid and that is because
our government chose to deal with the crisis
with a purely printing money strategy so every
single penny that the government used to support
the economy during Covid-19 was a printedpenny
they printed an enormous amount of money
this is not a normal well i think it's fair to
say a mature way to deal with an economic crisis
you know a sensible economy when there's a crisis
the government says return to the richest people
in the country and say look there's a crisis
we need you to contribute more you know this
is how a sensible country funds for example
awar you know you can't put it on the backs of
people who can't afford it,  we have a small group of
very extremely wealthy people in this country they
need to pay more but we didn't do that we didn't
turn to the rich and say you need to pay more
instead we just printed the money and that money
ended up being held by the rich so rather than
making the rich contribute to crisis we allowed
them to profit massively and that brings us on to
the next thing which people have to understand
which is that Covid; the first year of Covid
was the biggest ever single year increase
in wealth of the rich and super rich in
this country ever and it was enormous the average
billionaire in this country increased their wealth
by 630 million pounds in one year during Covid
the average billionaire and I'm not making those
numbers up that's from The Times rich list okay
which probably underestimates it to be honest so
number one thing to understand is that the
rich have accumulated a huge amount of money
number two is that the super rich have increased
their wealth enormously during Covid and it's
worth stopping and thinking about that right
is that normal is that healthy is it healthy
that when a country experiences
an enormous economic crisis
the rich get massively richer: is that healthy?
i think that's the thing to think about
and then that brings us on to the next
point which is if you make the rich richer
by giving them a ton of cash how does that affect
ordinary people because i think it's easy as an
to be like well you know this is politics of envy
right why do you care if the rich get richer you
know why why does it matter to you okay well what
happens what happens if you give a ton of cash to
rich people you know stop and think for a bit
you know why does that matter to you well the
reason is you know cash doesn't just sit in the
bank account right people use cash to buy things
and if you know if you go to the supermarket and
suddenly there's one guy in the supermarket who's
got like a million pounds he could pay way more
for everything than you can and anything you want
he can pay more for it so it's going to push
the price up you know this is most obvious in
the case of house prices right because ordinary
people haven't accumulated cash during Covid but
the wealthy i've got 60 or 70 grand per adult so
it's 140 grand if there's two adults in the family
well of course they're going to be able to buy the
house and your kid won't be able to buy the house
you see what i'm saying here so i think if you
deal with a crisis by giving money to the rich
number one ordinary people
don't know that's happened
number two prices will go up and then number three
ordinary people wont understand how or why
you see what i'm saying? the way we've managed with
the crisis it's like a magician's trick you know
they did this thing that meant everything seemed
to be solved without anyone having to be taxed
but it meant somebody around the back you don't
know suddenly got 100 grand in their account
and then they're pushing up the prices for
everything and you don't know why the prices have
gone up and then the newspapers and the media just
say cost of living crisis it must be something to
do with Vladimir Putin you know what i mean
as if we didn't just print 450 billion pounds
which ended up in the bank accounts of richer
people i think it's it's unbelievable the lack of
understanding that's happening what we're seeing
now is you know i've got two economic degrees
right 1 from London School of Economics and
1 from Oxford and unfortunately the state of the
economic profession is an absolute disaster now
most economists just have no idea what's happening
they're totally disconnected they don't you
know i was on a call with a bunch of economists
and i said you know they're they're just talking
about supply side issues blah blah blah and
i said well do you think it could be because of the
massive amount of printed money that was given out
and one of the economists said there's no
way it's that because it was only about
£200-300 per person that got printed and
you can go and look at the numbers and it's
£10,000 per person right what is happening
right now the economics discipline once again
is absolutely asleep at the wheel so you have
a situation where a ton of money was printed
£10,000 per adult -  £450,000,000,000 *IN TOTAL*
that's all gone to wealthy people of course that's
going to push prices up prices have been pushed
up and none of the economists are talking aboutit
the reason that is so important is because ifnone
of the economists understand what's happening
then this does not get fixed simple as that
simple as that right and you know the reason
i am a millionaire is because i predicted that
the 2008 crisis would not be fixed because it
was to do with inequality and the economists were
not talking about inequality and now the 2022 and
which will be the next 10 years of economic crisis
will not be fixed either because it's a crisis
of massive cash accumulation given to rich people
that nobody's talking about and nobody's gonna fix
and you know all of the newspapers owned by
billionaires so they're super happy about it
you know the chancellor is a billionaire he's
super happy about it the prime minister will
be will make millions of pounds as soon as he
quits office so he's super happy about it so
it's not gonna get fixed okay and i know that's
depressing to hear but that is the situation right
i want everybody out there to understand we will
continue to have a cost of living crisis of cost
living going up higher than wages as long as we
allow the rich and the super rich to accumulate
these enormous amounts of money okay so what
needs to be done okay so once you accept that we
dealt with the crisis by printing a ton of money
that ended up with the rich and the super rich
it should be obvious that the way to fix that
is to take money back from the rich and super
rich which is exactly what i suggested
in my first video on the channel again if
you haven't watched it you really should go
and watch it it's definitely worth watching
so are we doing that are we taking money back from
the rich and super rich well no definitely not in
fact we've raised taxes on ordinary workers whilst
not raising taxes at all on super rich people
so what we're doing instead
we're raising interest rates okay
it's worth pointing out that raising interest
rates is not the opposite of giving money to
the rich you know if you want to fix giving
money to the rich the answer is tax the rich
take money back from the rich if you want to fix
the Covid economic problem that is what you have
to do we're not doing that we're raising interest
rates so what does raising interest rates mean
that means that if you are a person
who has debts so if you have a mortgage
um well yeah that's the big one if you have a
mortgage if you have student debt for example
you will pay more money to the people who
people who hold cash those are the people
from whom you borrow which is rich people
the other group of people which has a massive
amount more debt now since pre Covid is
the government so basically taxpayers so
we caused the crisis or the government caused
the crisis by giving a ton of money to rich
people instead of taxing them and now to
fix the crisis we're going to say that
mortgage holders and taxpayers should pay more
money every month to the rich that's the that's
the proposed solution from our chancellor whose
father'sa billionaire and who's worth £200,000,000
so this is gonna get worse unfortunately because
now we've created a situation where the government
and everyone who has debt is gonna have to pay
more money every month to these rich people who
are stacking up money in their bank accounts so
the problem's not gonna get fixed unfortunately um
if we want to fix the problem then we need to
address the underlying problem of inequality
because when you give a ton of money to rich
people it doesn't just cause an inflation problem
it also exacerbates an already existing inequality
problem right we already had growing inequality in
the 20s before that and now we've suddenly given a
massive chunk of cash to the rich people and this
is the reason why not only are prices increasing
but they're increasing in such an unequal way
right rich people want to own assets they want
to own their natural resources they don't spend
a huge amount of money on paying people's wages
whereas ordinary people spend all their cash
straight away so if the money accumulates with
the rich you're going to see asset prices go up
and you're going to see natural resource prices
go up and you're going to see wages stay steady
so because of this massive increase in inequality
what you're going to see is and i think it's
important that people understand this you know if
we had just an inflation where all the prices went
up together it wouldn't actually be that bad right
okay energy price has gone up food prices gone up
but your wage has gone up by exactly the same so
actually you're pretty much fine but when you have
an inflation crisis with an inequality crisis
alongside it you also see the prices of assets
and the price of natural resources which basically
means your food and energy going up higher than
your wage so it creates this cost of living
crisis so i think whenever you hear the words
cost of living crisis i want you to interpret that
as inequality crisis because that is essentially
what it is and we saw a very similar thing happen
after 2008 when essentials (food, energy, housing)
those prices went up wages didn't and
that's because we dealt with a 2008 crisis
just in the same way we we are dealing with the
2020 crisis by massively increasing inequality so
if we want to change this it's very important
that we reframe the way this crisis is described
away from being a cost of living crisis
and towards what it actually is which is
an inequality crisis and that we understand that
Covid massively increased inequality that's not
being talked about in the media at all and
now we understand that code would cause a
massive increase in cash accumulation by richer
people that's not being talked about at all so
what i'm hoping people take away from this is
a very clear understanding of what's happened
we dealt with the crisis by printing money that
money ended up with the rich that caused two
simultaneous crises one of inequality and
one of inflation and together they caused
what we're calling a cost of living crisis but
fundamentally it's being caused by this massive
gift essentially of cash from government
to rich people and the only way to fix it
is to take money back from the rich people um
we're we're filming this just after the Russian
invasion of Ukraine - i'm not going to pretend i'm a
war expert because i'm not i'm just going to focus
on how this is going to affect people economically
and as you probably predict it's not good news um
these are regions which export a lot of energy and
food basically to the west um to europe to western
europe and uh it's going to cause these prices to
go up even more so what we are going to see
now is even more increasing energy price even
more increasing food price at the worst possible
time and i want everybody watching to understand
that does not cause a cost of living crisis
for everyone because there's a small minority
people in this country who remember have made
their biggest ever increase in wealth in the
last two years so these guys are laughing they
can afford to pay a little bit more for their
food and energy they can afford to pay it the
people who are suffering are ordinary people
and this is this is not simply a law of nature
this is because we dealt with a crisis in such a
way that the rich got enormous gifts of money and
ordinary people got tax rises you know it doesn't
have to be this way it can be changed but only
if we reframe this crisis as what it really is
a crisis of inequality and if we do something
about it which has to mean taxing the rich
Any Good.... Yeah?